today I'll be speaking with Andrew
Seidel who's a civil rights and
constitutional attorney with the Freedom
From Religion Foundation where he serves
as director of strategic response he
works to keep church and state separate
as they should be his first book the
founding myth why Christian nationalism
is unamerican will be out in May of 2019
Andrew so great to talk to you I've seen
interviews that you've done and I think
that there's just so much material right
now to discuss that you work on
so maybe just to start somewhere when we
talk about church and state separation
is this a concept that the average
American has an accurate grasp on or do
you think that there are sort of some
basics about what we mean by separation
of church and state that maybe are
missing from the the lay person's
understanding I definitely think there
are some basics that are missing and I
would I would say not just from the lay
person's understanding but even from
experts in this area of law you know we
heard in judge Kavanaugh hearings this
week how some people sometimes conflate
the separation of state in church with
hostility towards religion and and
that's absolutely not the case and in
fact you can't have true religious
freedom the freedom of religion without
a government that is free from religion
it's just the two cannot coexist you
have to have a secular government it's a
prerequisite for genuine religious
liberty and and to me that's the biggest
thing that I think people don't
understand about state church separation
is that it protects every American and
when you talk about that that separation
of the the infrastructure of law there
is the often discussed Establishment
Clause idea of the the concept of the
government establishing one religion
over others or religion over
non-religion for example but when you
actually want to expand and take a
deeper look at the law what other
relevant points of law are important
when we think about what what the
foundation is for separation of church
and state the foundation of state church
separation is it's right there in the
Constitution you know the Constitution
mentions religion
three times before it was amended the
only mention of it was in article 6
which prohibits religious tests for
public office and I mean this is
actually really striking especially for
the founding generation now at the time
no nation had ever divorced religion and
government the way the founders chose to
in fact our Constitution is entirely
godless it doesn't mention any
supernatural being at all which was also
you know this unique contribution of the
founding generation and then later on a
couple years later they had the First
Amendment which says that Congress shall
make no law respecting an establishment
of religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof and those are the only
three mentions of religion in the entire
document and all of them are
exclusionary right they're meant to keep
religion out of government and
government out of religion so it really
it begins and ends with the Constitution
and it's very clear if you look at that
document even just the words you don't
have to study you don't have to be an
attorney that the government has no as
Alexander Hamilton put it no particle of
spiritual jurisdiction right it just
doesn't have the power to get involved
in religion one way or another you'll
sometimes hear from some people in the
United States we don't need to
necessarily characterize who that the
founding fathers were religious and thus
you sort of have to read between the
lines at the separation of church and
state stuff and that they fully intended
that okay maybe maybe some of these
things are written until into the law to
prevent it from getting out of hand but
that really this is at at core a quote
Christian nation is that a leaf forget
about the morality or the logic of it
right
is that a legally valuable analysis or
is it as simple as what matters is
what's written no I mean that that's a
completely flawed analysis and actually
that's the subject of my book that comes
out in May I go through and debunk the
entire idea of a Christian nation or
that we are even founded on
judeo-christian principles you know both
of these are are flawed ideas and you
can argue about whether or not the
founders were religious whether or not
they were Christian whether or not they
were evangelical Christian you know
Jesus rose from the dead kind of Chris
or even deists but but at the end of the
day it doesn't really matter because we
know that they wanted state and church
separate that they wanted these two
different spheres of power and they
didn't want them intersecting or
overlapping and that's why Thomas
Jefferson chose the metaphor of a wall
right this isn't of a fine line that is
easily overstepped it's a wall it's
meant to be tall and strong and
impregnable and it's meant to not just
benefit all of us to all of our citizens
but even the religious citizens right I
mean the people who benefited most from
the founding generation were religious
minorities and they were very supportive
of state church separation for that idea
Catholics and Southern Baptists were
among the the biggest supporters of
state church separation because they
were minority religions and they didn't
want the government weighing in and
coercing them or even pressuring them
however slightly into one religion or
another or benefiting the majority
religion which is certainly something
we're seeing happening today yeah what
what do you make of I mean I've we can
talk about examples of ten commandments
at a federal building we can talk about
manger displays and some of these other
notable newsworthy cases but at its core
isn't the fact that Christmas is a
federal holiday an establishment of
religion I mean I know that it's sort of
like it's it's almost too obvious and
and it's not a battle that I think we're
gonna win anytime soon but it does that
count as an establishment of religion by
the government sure and as someone who
is on the front lines of the war on
Christmas every year I I would I would
absolutely argue that it does I mean the
the way that courts have looked at this
particular issue is they've said well
because there is a valid reason for the
government to want to close in this case
it just happens that most people are
Christian they would want to take that
day off anyway the government would
essentially shut down if 70 percent of
the workers took the day off that is in
their minds a in courts minds sometimes
a secular purpose behind the holiday so
they have upheld it however we've
actually the Freedom From Religion
Foundation has actually gotten laws like
that struck down when the purpose is
very clearly religious so here in
Wisconsin there was a
Friday holiday and I don't remember the
exact reason that the Legislature passed
this law but it was essentially
something along the lines of you know we
want to make sure everybody can go to
church and worship and the government
struck down that or the excuse me the
Court struck down that holiday when FFRF
brought the lawsuit because it was
overtly religious when we talked about
the Supreme Court decision on same-sex
marriage which held or affirmed that at
the state level you cannot ban same-sex
marriage that was the end of one very
important discussion which was what is
going to ultimately happen when in terms
of individual couples getting married
but it was very clearly only the
beginning for a whole sort of new front
in the battle against LGBT rights and
I've been talking about it since day one
which is arguing along lines of
so-called religious freedom to
discriminate in different ways against
LGBT individuals or people perceived to
be LGBT individuals but who are
discriminated against in the same way
talk a little bit about the relatively
well funded campaigns that now are
operating and whether it's about baking
cakes or employer employer employee
relations related to religion and some
of these other fronts how would you
generally characterize what's now being
used as a way to fight against LGBT
rights under the guise of so-called
religious freedom yeah I mean there's
there's so much to unpack there we could
talk about that for hours but basically
what is happening is the Religious Right
is attempting to redefine religious
freedom and actually a better way to put
it might be that they're attempting to
weaponize religious freedom you know
they're turning it into what used to be
this this shield to protect an
individual's right to believe and in
some cases act on that belief in a way
that wouldn't harm others into now a way
to impose their religion on other people
we're seeing it in the Hobby Lobby case
from 2014 where this massive company is
using religion to impose their religious
beliefs on their employers and as you
pointed out after the obergefell this
that equalised marriage for LGBTQ
individuals you know that push kind of
kicked into overdrive and what we're
what you're really seeing is the
Religious Right trying to use God as a
license to discriminate and this is the
big push that we are fighting back
against here at the Freedom From
Religion Foundation we've been fighting
against it since before the Hobby Lobby
case we we saw this coming we saw the
attempt to redefine religious liberty
coming and we've been trying to push
back against it and finally it does seem
to be that the country is sort of waking
up to this idea that you know just
because you happen to have a belief and
it happens to be religious doesn't mean
you get to act on that belief no you
know they want to say I can do this
because my God says so and it doesn't
matter what the impact is on other
people but courts have never decided
that though this Supreme Court and the
shifting Supreme Court I would not put
it past them we're coming we've come
dangerously close and I think we're all
possibly on the verge of a seismic shift
here one of the areas of concern to me
about the shift from the conversation
about can two men or two women get
married at the state level to what we're
talking about now the use of so-called
religious freedom to discriminate is
that one Supreme Court decision made it
super clear states can't ban same-sex
marriage period that is it's very cut
and dry in a sense or at least
relatively cut and dry religious freedom
can be argued in so many different
contexts and in so many different ways
that it seems more complex to me to
imagine that there can be any single
decision at any level that would prevent
that from being done because you can
argue it in so many different ways is
that accurate or could there be some
umbrella solution here no I think that's
a that's an excellent observation on
your part and actually this has been
addressed by the Supreme Court way back
in the 1870s they said that to allow a
citizen to exempt themselves from the
law because of their religion that
government could only exist in name
under such circumstances right you would
have the law would become Swiss cheese
where anybody who believed in any
particular belief as long as it was real
would be able to exempt themselves from
whatever law of a says they say burdens
that religious belief I mean that is a
recipe for anarchy not for religious
freedom and honestly they're doing a
good job of pushing that narrative I
mean it you know in the masterpiece cake
shop case at its core that case was
about discrimination right I mean it was
a it was a couple was discriminated
against by a business but the story that
everybody talked about was the religious
freedom of not a baker but a bakery and
that I that is just amazing to me how
much they pushed this narrative and how
far they've advanced it this is a good
spot to pause with Andrew sidle from the
Freedom From Religion Foundation we will
pick up our conversation with him
tomorrow starting with we'll get to the
Trump administration but we will start
with the relationship between Freedom
From Religion and freedom of speech
which is an increasingly popular topic
particularly in some on online enclaves
we'll pick it up there Andrew thank you
my pleasure we are continuing our
conversation with Andrew Seidel who is a
civil rights and constitutional attorney
with the Freedom From Religion
Foundation he serves as director of
strategic response works to keep state
and church separate his first book is
out in May 2018 was out May 2018 the
founding myth why Christian nationalism
is unamerican let's pick up our
conversation if we can Andrew with the
idea of the inter player connection
between freedom from and freedom of
religion and the First Amendment because
this is something that I think you know
we started part one of the interview
talking about misconceptions about
freedom from religion and freedom of
religion and separation of church and
state
there are numerous arguments that are
often made by those who are de facto
supporting discrimination in many cases
that what what we might see what you and
I might see or some others who have sort
of the political leanings that that we
might have see as discrimination among
religious lines is merely the expression
of speech and that is something that
cannot be curtailed is there a gray area
when we talk about freedom from and of
religion and speech or are the limits
pretty clear as to when
we're talking about one versus the other
sure well and just a quick quick note
the book comes out in May 2019 I think
that was my fault but I think to your
question the the limits used to be clear
but in recent say two decades there has
been a push and this is deliberate it's
a legal strategy by the Religious Right
to conflate religious freedom and free
speech the goal was because free speech
has been so carefully protected in this
nation and because religious liberty is
really not under threat in this country
right there's I mean especially if you
are a Christian the danger that a
government which is run you know I mean
how much of our federal legislature are
always run by Christians you're talking
to ninety-nine percent probably there
was no real danger to Christianity from
a religious freedom standpoint in this
nation so one of the things that the
Religious Right started doing was taking
their arguments to court along free
speech lines and they did this
successfully in the school context and
now they're starting to expand it out
and you've saw it in the masterpiece
cake shop case kind of writ large
and I mean the striking thing about that
case is there was there was no request
for a specific cake that said something
they didn't actually even get a chance
this couple didn't even actually get a
chance to discuss with the Baker what
they wanted on their cake so he didn't
have any idea of what expression he was
going to have to give so there was there
was actually no free speech issue in
that case just because of the facts but
again they did a really great job of
promoting that narrative and conflating
it with the religious freedom narrative
so I the lines used to be very clear but
they've done a good job from a legal
standpoint of blurring them
yeah and it's it's being done not it's
not being done in good faith in other
words as you're pointing out a good job
is done because that that side benefits
from the blurring of those lines and
that kind of gets me to the Trump
administration where is an organization
like the Freedom From Religion
Foundation most concerned when it comes
to the actions of the current
administration in the context of
separation of church and state religious
freedom just
I mean that that's a that's a tough
question to answer we've actually we
sued the Trump administration over their
religious liberty executive order that
they put out on the National Day of
Prayer
last year in 2017 we took them to court
that same day
actually over that the we've sued them
about the White House Bible study that
they have about getting access to
records to that I think overall probably
the most alarming thing if you care
about a secular government if you care
about religious freedom and the true
sense and state church separation is the
reshaping of the federal judiciary is is
incredibly alarming if Trump and Mitch
McConnell get their way about one in
every seven judges on the federal bench
will have been appointed by Trump by the
end of the year and that is just hugely
alarming and then of course there could
be two on the Supreme Court that he'd
already have appointed so that to me is
probably the the biggest problem that we
currently are facing because it's a
problem that we're gonna have for 30 or
40 years so how does so we've all
started to read about Bret Cavanaugh's
ideas about abortion for example and
there's a very clear link between
religion and opposition to abortion but
it's more complex than that right the
ways in which a Supreme Court justice
for decades in many cases can influence
issues of separation of church and state
go way beyond whether roe v wade might
someday be repealed can you talk about
the different ways in which a Supreme
Court justice can impact these issues
the types of cases that come up I mean
absolutely and it's it's virtually
without limit the impact they can have
and we're actually already seeing it
just with the retirement of Anthony
Kennedy lower court judges got an idea
of what type of nominee Trump would put
up and they're starting to alter their
opinions you know in two of the cases
that FFRF has taken we got a cross on
public land in a public park in Florida
struck down declared unconstitutional no
cross has ever been upheld as
constitutional in a public park and the
same thing there was a cross on
city seal in Pennsylvania both courts
struck those down but in the opinions
that the court wrote they put all this
regret they said you know we wish we
didn't have to decide this case this way
we think that Establishment Clause and
state church separation that that area
of law is a shambles the court needs to
step in and overturn our opinion we're
deciding the way precedent dictates but
we think we shouldn't have to and
decisions like that were unthinkable a
couple of years ago and I think had the
election gone differently and appointees
to the Supreme Court gone differently I
do not believe opinions like that would
have been written so is that like a
signal is that a in the same way that
absolutely apologies for what some might
find to be a bad analogy but is this
sort of like we've seen white
supremacists claim that even though
Trump's not really saying the thing he's
signaling in a certain way where if you
know the language you understand what
he's kind of getting at is that the same
type of thing that we're seeing court
signal I don't I don't even think it's a
dog whistle I think they're being very
open about it and the reason they're
being open about it is because we know
for instance what Brett Kavanaugh thinks
of the wall of separation he has
specifically said that the wall of
separation is a bad metaphor based on
bad history he said that and basically
any religious artifact in this nation
whether it be prayer before the
legislature in God We Trust on our money
under God in the pledge as long as
there's a history and tradition behind
it that it should be upheld essentially
he's arguing that if something has been
around for a long time we aren't going
to apply the First Amendment to it as
long as religions involved I mean you
can imagine where that would leave us in
terms of slavery segregation women's
rights that that idea that history and
tradition allows us to do an end-around
around the Constitution is ridiculous
but it's something that he has
specifically and he talked about it
again in his hearings and this was just
in a speech last year they said he is a
wrecking ball aimed at the wall of
separation is very dangerous nominee
that all being said and and sort of
thinking about Trump and Mike Pence as
well because that sort of relates to my
next question we don't have to speculate
about impeachment or the 25th amendment
or anything
like that but I have been clear that
there are ways in which Mike Pence would
be a bigger disaster than Donald Trump
not in all ways but there are ways in
which he would it strikes me that
because of his ideological religious
background when it comes to the issues
you work on Pence could actually be more
of a threat do you agree I think that
could very well be true if you're if
we're talking about our particular area
of the law in keeping state and church
separate I do think that's probably true
you know Mike Pence infamously signed
the Indiana Religious Freedom
Restoration Act into law a couple years
ago despite huge outcry and backlash to
doing so and that is what we were
talking about earlier it is it is a law
that redefines religious liberty and it
essentially gives that license to
discriminate or it attempts to give that
license to discriminate to Christians so
he would certainly be a bigger threat I
think than Trump to State Church
separation though Trump is pretty pretty
bad so far last thing I want to touch on
when it comes to fighting some of these
cases in court I my sense is because
most people aren't lawyers they may not
understand the sort of details on which
some of these decisions can ultimately
hinge so can you give us a little bit of
a sense of the spectrum of like you
mentioned across on on public grounds or
I think maybe in parks you said has
never been upheld as constitutional that
seems super cut and dry but can you give
us some examples of how sometimes it can
seem as though oh this is obviously
unconstitutional this obviously violates
separation of church and state but that
the devil sort of ends up being in the
details and and technicalities or
seeming technique' out technicalities
can determine whether or not something
is upheld or struck down sure so first
the Freedom From Religion Foundation we
are 15 and one since the beginning of
2016 in Cork we are we are winning these
cases time and time again but when we do
lose especially before 2016 it's often
on technicalities and one of the biggest
ones is called standing and basically
this means that courts are
saying you don't have you the Freedom
From Religion Foundation or you're
plaintiffs don't have an injury or an
interest in this case so we're not even
gonna hear the case it's not they aren't
getting to the merits of the legal
question they're just saying you don't
even get to bring this case a really
good example a really frustrating an
example is the National Day of Prayer
and I mean a National Day of Prayer
would be I think to any law student to
anybody even mildly versed in this that
would seem like a state Church problem
probably a violation and the Freedom
From Religion Foundation took a case on
that we won it at the federal district
court level the lowest level and then it
was appealed to the circuit court and
the circuit court said you cannot bring
this case and if that means that nobody
can bring this case and nobody can
challenge the National Day of Prayer so
be it so essentially what they did was
using jurisdiction using this fiction of
jurisdiction they said that nobody can
challenge a clearly unconstitutional law
citizens don't have the ability to
enforce the Constitution and I mean it's
it's an injustice of the highest degree
but it happens all the time
Andrew you and the organization are
doing really great work we've been
speaking with Andrew Seidel who's a
civil rights and constitutional attorney
with the Freedom From Religion
Foundation the book is out May of next
year May of 2019 the founding myth why
Christian nationalism is unamerican
Andrew thank you so much for talking to
us today it was truly a pleasure thank
you for having me on